so how many times this holiday season
maybe this has happened to you you
finish up your shopping at a store
and as you're checking out the clerk
says hey would you like to open one of
our store credit cards
chances are that's probably happened a
few times kirsten joyce is on your side
tonight with important tips to keep in
mind
denise whether someone is new to credit
cards or a seasoned card holder
the experts say the store counter is not
where you want to be making a big
decision like opening a new credit card
in fact most retail store credit cards
tend to have higher aprs if you're
paying off your balance every month
that's not going to be
much of an issue but if you're
considering a larger purchase that will
take a few months to pay off
it may not be the right thing also
there's a big difference between
deferred interest and a zero percent
introductory rate
now we caught up with nathan grant of
creditinsider.com
where you can find out everything you
need to know about credit cards and
balances and whatnot
how to build the credit and the top five
credit cards he adds that security is
another thing to keep in mind while
online shopping
a credit card in general offers better
protection against fraud compared to a
debit card
and mobile and digital wallets offer
another layer of security
those are things like google pay apple
pay and things like paypal if you're
shopping online
if any of the retailers you're shopping
at this holiday offer up that as an
option for payment
that's even more secure because what
those apps do is you
uh you will pre-load your credit card or
debit card number on to those
apps yeah but what happens is they
create it's called a one-time use number
called tokenization so
the number that actually is used to do
those charges
wherever your whatever merchant accepts
them isn't even your actual number so
it provides another layer of security
he adds if there is a credit card that
you've paid off and you're not
using you might be tempted to close it
but if it doesn't have an annual fee
the age of your credit account goes into
your credit
score it's actually a good thing so the
longer you have established credit the
better your credit score so you will
want to keep that account open